Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 25th episode!
I thought you were going to say that's a critical number.
It is a critical number too!
It's 25 Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Wow for Ruffians that are joining us today for
Maybe the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMUKO!
Get it?
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMUKO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, if you could please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
It would make us really happy.
Yeah, let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
What's wrong, Moco-chan?
Did you not like it when I said the thing you were gonna say at the same time?
I was gonna say that this time.
Which one do you like more, Ruffians?
Do you think it's better?
Together or...
Did I steal Moco-chan's thunder?
Stupid.
Together.
I guess I'm not angry.
If the Ruffians like it then.
It's too early for anger, Moco-chan.
That's true.
Before I get more angry.
Do any Ruffians happen to see Peron?
Let's see!
De-den!
That looks like Pero's been spotted with a new friend!
With a Ruffian's pet turtle!
Hopefully Pero's being a good influence on your friend.
I don't know, Moco-chan.
You can, like, uh... Turtles... can take the shells, right?
Pero's not gonna do something like that, right?
Do you have to be a good enough friend to take a turtle's shell?
I don't know.
Can't you take it by force?
What if Pero tries that?
I don't know.
He can be sort of nasty sometimes, you know?
So if he feels, like... a bit jealous of the shell, thinks it's justified, then maybe he'll do what he can to get his own way, you know?
Yeah...
But if he's truly a friend then he shouldn't, right?
But you know, I feel like... I feel a bit... It's nice that Pero can make new friends, you know?
And you know, a friend that has a warm and protective shell sounds pretty nice.
True, you know?
I would like that.
You can retreat into it whenever you need it.
Sounds pretty comfy, huh?
Could be good, it could be good.
I don't know, maybe.
Maybe it would be a good idea to keep a close eye on Perroccino.
He goes on his own way.
Or shells can't be removed from a turtle.
They can't?
It seems that we don't have much information about turtles, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Well then, your friend is safe.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe... Well, you know... Yeah, Pero should go away soon.
As long as maybe you're not feeding a turtle pudding.
Turtles eat vegetables and... I could imagine a turtle eating pudding.
But can they eat sugary desserts?
Uh, veggies have sugars in them too.
They do.
Maybe some more.
Maybe don't feed the turtle pudding though.
Keep Pero away.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, please let us know if you see Pero around again, okay?
You can let us know with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Now, I think some Ruffians might have noticed, but
It's one month since membership opened!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's one month since Doggy Pack.
How did time go so fast, right?
And you know, today's also our 25th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah, it's double special, right?
Thank you so much for watching for all years and more.
And thank you for wanting to be a special part of a special doggy pack too.
BAU BAU!
You know it!
The other day, we also uploaded a very special video for the doggy pack, so make sure you check it out, okay?
I didn't think it was that.
You know what?
We're gonna be playing Fall Guys together on Saturday, too!
You know, Fall Guys is free, so that means all you need to do is just download it beforehand and you can join and hopefully play with us, so even if you've never played before...
Enough!
As for other things that we're going to do with the doggy pack, we'd really, really, really like to do a watch-along soon.
But the one thing that's making it a little bit tricky is that we can't decide.
We can't decide on what to watch.
It's a tough one.
We'll continue thinking.
Thank you so much for being here!
Thank you for supporting us on this journey!
BAU BAU!
Extra happy time.
Now, this is a little... Is this not a story?
Ruffians... We actually got a phone call the other day, but... FUWAMOCO...
We're really, really bad with phone calls.
Are you?
Ruffians, what do you do when you get a phone call?
You answer it.
Answer the phone?
But... But... You don't know who's gonna be on the other side, right?
Ignore it.
See, that's what we do.
Yeah, we almost never ever answer them because it's just... It's too scary.
But... It's angry, you know?
Yeah.
But actually, this one... This one was from Mama Puppy!
Yeah, we got a phone call from Mama Puppy.
And this time, she said she had something to share with us.
And that's not really normal for her.
She usually just calls about normal stuff, you know?
Not that she has something to share.
You know?
And what it was, was that she actually wanted to share a new song that she just heard that was from Japan.
And supposedly, it reminded her of us.
Can you tell what song that was, Ruffians?
Can you guess?
Yeah, we were able to guess right away without her saying anything more, but... What song do you think it was?
Ruffians ain't no gonna pull a mama puppy right.
Right.
I guess the Ruffians just can't guess it, huh Moco-chan?
I saw it multiple times.
I just saw it!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Oh, it's so, so trendy, but I don't know between, you know, between idol and nante tatte idol.
You remember we sang during a Rock n' Rawr Party, right?
Nante tatte idol.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think between the two though, we prefer nante tatte idol, right?
Yeah.
But you know, we are happy that maybe Mama Puppy heard a new song and it reminded her of us.
Thank you Mama Puppy!
Yeah, I don't know.
We were just surprised we could guess it right away.
But if it's the mama song, that would be surprising.
I wouldn't be able to guess that.
No.
Yeah.
End of story time.
Hopefully we don't get any more phone calls.
Even if they're from Mama Puppy, that'd be scary.
Why is it scary?
Phone calls are scary.
Ah, phone calls are scary, but if it's Mama Puppy, it's fine.
But it's still scary.
BAU BAU!
I thought we were good.
I thought we were good too.
We were so so close, Moco-chan.
I thought we were good.
Well, Ruffians, you know, yesterday we had an extra, extra special collab with Tally-senpai!
We participated in a special twin showdown.
Showdown.
Twin showdown.
Yeah.
That was produced by Tally-senpai too.
What did you think?
We had fun.
We had a lot of fun.
But there was one question.
Maybe more questions, but at least one question that maybe some Ruffians were surprised about.
Was there one question you were surprised about?
Ship questions?
I'm seeing a lot of questions.
Well, you know, there was one question.
This is what we thought.
We thought it was a misunderstanding.
That the Ruffians misunderstood.
It's not our misunderstanding, it's your misunderstanding.
Okay?
What was one of the weirdest gifts Moco-chan has given you?
Yeah, and I responded, a ring.
Yeah.
It's not weird.
It's not the kind of ring that you might be thinking.
So don't misunderstand that.
Even though the graphic sort of looks like different types of rings, I just wanted two that looked the same, okay?
Matching ring.
I didn't have options.
Don't think of other things, okay?
It's nothing special.
They weren't anything expensive, okay?
Do you think I would buy an expensive ring?
Do I, like, look like that kind of... Do I look like that kind of demon guide dog where I can be buying expensive rings?
No.
I... I can't.
They're special to us.
You know, not many twin sisters are as fortunate as us to be so close and to be able to spend so much time together, so... You know, we feel really lucky.
One day, you know, maybe there might be a day that comes and our time together will be less and less, you know?
So we really treasure every day that we have together, too.
That's why Moco-chan got those rings for us, right?
It was a surprise, right?
Yeah, but Moco-chan messed it up.
I did!
Yeah, I did.
You know, I'm not used to wearing rings either.
So, I measured the wrong spot on the wrong figure.
Finger.
And both the rings are too loose on my thumb.
I think especially for Fuwawa, if she was to wear it, she'd lose it right away.
It's just too loose.
But, but, you know, it's okay because it's still precious.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a symbol, right?
Yeah, we both don't wear rings really anyways, so it's kind of hard to get used to, too.
Oh, we could get them resized.
But that's tricky.
Right.
It costs money.
But you know more than anything, it's the meaning and the symbolism and the thought that counts, right?
Surprise gifts are always good, right?
Especially when we don't give gifts to each other too much, right?
It's the thought that matters.
Are you good?
I think so.
You understand, right, Ruffians?
It's not anything...
Not anything like you might think.
It's just, you know, special sister rings.
That's it.
I'm sure Nerissa is the same, too.
What do you mean?
We're three sisters, too.
Oh, three sisters!
That's a lot of rings.
Do they make three rings?
When I was looking, they make a lot of matching rings.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Wait.
We have to ask Nerissa too!
It's totally normal.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO.
We have something.
Something to confess.
Hi.
But I don't know how I feel about this, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Yeah.
Actually, we're both a bit concerned about you.
We're concerned.
You know, did you notice anything weird on Twitter?
Hi.
Did you?
Huh?
You are, but we're still concerned.
Haven't tip?
What do you mean?
You're not looking at Twitter.
Choco-sensei.
No, no, no Choco-sensei.
Okay, I don't see any Ruffians in all this.
This is why we're concerned, okay?
Ruffians!
You know, I tweet for today's FUWAMOCO Morning.
Moco-chan, wait.
Wait.
You really didn't notice something strange?
We tweeted something strange.
I'm not a single Ruffian to notice deshita, Moco-chan.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Yeah, you say it.
You say it!
The tweet was a bit weird, okay?
For today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Here it is, okay?
De-den.
That's amazing.
And then she asked me if we could read it over.
And we couldn't stop laughing together.
Yeah.
We're just a laugh buddle.
So then Moco-chan said that we should tweet it just as it is.
Yeah.
And I haven't seen any Ruffians here, but... Yeah, if you catch it.
Nobody did.
Uh-uh.
Are you reading our tweets, Ruffians?
Are you?
Are you actually?
Yeah.
You're not just looking at the pretty picture.
We didn't answer a question.
Right.
What?
Has the week been going by for you as it has passed for us?
Has it, Ruffians?
Has the week been going by for you as fast for us?
I don't even know how to fix this sentence.
It has to be changed completely.
You get it?
English is hard.
Just a bit sometimes.
Just a bit.
It's good to know that the Ruffians aren't reading our tweets.
No!
Please read our tweets, okay?
Okay.
I'm gonna be waiting for your report.
Thank you.
I'm waiting for your responses, okay?
Moco-chan is too.
I guess, maybe.
BAU BAU!
Nothing else weird on Twitter.
Please use your eyes, okay?
Yeah, okay.
Use your eyes.
Well, maybe this next part will help you use your eyes.
Maybe wake up a little bit.
I have something to say!
Hi.
You know,
I think it's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
Hey sleepyhead.
Yes, you.
Sleepyhead.
Are you awake?
Are you awake?! !
Hopefully you are now.
Even though you might not have gotten much of a rest last night, you're gonna make everything today amazing!
You're already up and going, you know it.
I know you can do it.
No matter what silly things try to take you down, you'll be fine!
You know, they're just out of your control, so let them roll off of you.
Just trust yourself, trust your instincts, trust your smile, and you'll be good!
I trust you.
So you should too, okay?
Don't let the little things ruin your strife!
You're amazing, and we'll all make it to the weekend!
Just keep going!
I believe you'll be O-E-O-K!
Ganba-shin-ya!
BAU BAU!
Howl.
Are you okay, huh?
Moco-chan, you know what?
You need an A to be ALK and Moco-chan's name doesn't have any A's in it.
But guess who does?
I was thinking maybe the Ruffians.
Ruffians.
Fancy.
Let's see who our Doggie of the Day is today, Moco-chan!
We have... De-den!
Two doggies of the day!
It's Snickers and Brownie!
Very appropriate name.
They look almost as close as we are, Moco-chan.
But, you know, it's nice that they get along and like to cuddle up to each other.
Yeah.
Moco-chan's always really cool, so... Yeah.
Ruffians.
Moco-chan's just so cool that she tries to cuddle up to me all the time for warmth when I'm busy.
I don't know why I'm cool.
I'm just cool.
It's annoying.
It's a bit annoying.
We definitely don't have the air-conditioning going.
But sometimes, you know, when I'm called the Moco-chan there, so, you know, it's good, it's good.
But hopefully, you know, hopefully they don't annoy each other, you know.
They're always good buddies.
Right, but it seems like they also joined us for a stream of Planetarium!
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Well, I hope that they enjoyed it and maybe didn't get too emotional.
It'd be bad if they started going howl, howl, howl.
Yeah.
But on that note, how do they BAU BAU?
How does Neko sound like?
I think a bit creamy.
Creamy?
Yeah.
Like BAU BAU.
Really?
I was thinking like a BAU.
BAU.
I think it's the same.
Yeah.
Creamy, yeah.
And brownie!
BAUPA!
Really?
A bit fancy.
I was thinking like a BAU BAU.
Ah, that's good too.
Really?
Yeah.
Well you know, Snickers and Brownie, they have each other to annoy, which I guess is good, because then you don't get annoyed.
They'll annoy each other, not you.
You're busy.
But I guess more than anything, you know they have each other to keep company, and they get along really well, and they love each other, and I'm sure they love you even more too!
BAU BAU!
And for our next corner, the Ruffians go for a walk.
Ruffians, you've been going for walks, right?
What a nice day for sightseeing in France!
That's so cool.
You know, and it's really wonderful that Gura-senpai went along with you.
Right!
All dressed up in her dinosaur outfit, too.
Thank you.
Right?
You know, it makes the trip even that much more special.
Since you're in France, did you eat anything yummy?
I don't really know what France is known for when it comes to food.
French bread.
Bread?
French bread?
You eat bread.
Have some good bread!
Bread, bread, bread!
We hope you have a great time in France!
BAU BAU BOKU!
Time for our Question of the Day!
We have...
De-den!
Oh!
Got a little question.
Okay.
Who is making the thumbnail?
Good question.
Well, I think we maybe mentioned it before, right?
But Pero does!
Yeah.
Even though, you know, Pero can be really nasty at times, we're also really thankful that Pero makes the thumbnails for us, you know?
That's why we gotta make sure that he's at least kinda safe.
That's the reason why we went to look at him.
And I can make thumbnails too, Moco-chan!
Maybe not so much, but things are really busy for us, so having Peron make them gives us more time to prepare for things.
You know, iron out issues, as well as get some more sleep.
But we also do let Pero know what kind of ideas we have for them.
And then Pero gets creative and then surprises us!
Thank you Pero for helping us out so much.
Yeah, I guess he can be sort of great sometimes.
That's why he's the Great Perroccino.
The great stands for great at making thumbnails.
I wouldn't go that far.
Yeah.
Right, so even if Pero kinda gets a bit annoyed, we kinda wanna throw him around or kick him or stomp him, we gotta remember, think of the thumbnails, right?
Think of the thumbnails.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Very good question, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Good question.
Yeah.
Well, for our next team, we have... De-den.
Speaking of thumbnails.
I'm alone.
I'm alone, and I'm ghost hunting on my own.
Ruffians, please, please be there to help me, okay?
Moco-chan won't be there, so I'll have to depend on you for support.
Let's figure out the ghost together!
Why are you unblessing?
No, Ruffians.
It's gonna be scary, that's why I need you there!
But hopefully we can figure out the ghosts and then we can buy some flashlights.
Flashlights.
I wish I could hold multiple flashlights, you know?
And like, just be like a, become a Dekotora and just be like, wow!
Look at all my lights!
It might be catching the ghosts a bit difficult, but that's okay.
It won't be scary then.
Please tell me, okay, Ruffians, my first time all on my own.
I have phasmophobia too.
BAU BAU!
And if we take another peek at our schedule, well, on Thursday, Moco-chan will be back, and we're going back and continuing our journey in the Zelda Archimede of Time!
Last time, you know, we finally became Big Link, and we're gonna have to get rid of Ganondorf.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Please join us, we're playing it on the N64 too, so it's a bit special, right?
And then, on Sunday, we're going back to Donkey Kong Country!
Bananas, bananas!
But you know, I don't know, that's what you say right now, but...
It feels like last time we were able to get much, much better.
Hopefully our luck continues.
We have lots and lots of many lives.
BAU BAU!
It was another fun 25th FUWAMOCO Morning.
Another 25th.
Another FUWAMOCO Morning.
A special 25th one.
But before
We say BAU BAU for now.
We'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today.
Our 25th episode.
25 wonderful Extra Special Ruffians.
Can we do it, Moco-chan?
25?
Can we count that many?
Let's do our best, okay?
Junai!
BAU BAU!
Ann!
Nekojita!
BAU BAU!
Me!
Nabe!
BAU BAU!
Felix!
Sophie!
BAU BAU!
Lifty!
Tecca!
BAU BAU!
Nick!
Mifu.
BAU BAU!
Catstar.
Maiko.
BAU BAU!
Notebox.
Potato.
BAU BAU!
Yahiro.
Death Mirror.
BAU BAU!
Ashura.
Yuki.
BAU BAU!
To every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!